Michael Wendler canceln weil er
corona-verschwörung erzählt ich hoffe
dass Michael Wendler damit seine
Karriere beendet hat Harry Potter
canceln weil die Autorin j.k rowling
sich transvog geäußert hat ich denke
wenn jemand nicht einsichtig ist und
abstreitet einen Fehler begangen zu
haben dann muss ich meine Konsequenz
daraus ziehen und sagen gut Frau Rowling
dann ist unsere Beziehung hiermit
beendet true foods canceln weil die
Firma ihre Produkte mit rassistischen
Werbeslogans bewirkt ich habe truefruit
komplett aus meinem aus meinem
Dunstkreis geschmissen eine mögliche
Gefahr wir sprechen nicht mehr
miteinander schließen Meinungen aus mit
denen wir nicht einverstanden sind es
gibt kaum noch Vielfalt eine mögliche
Chance wir machen auf Missstände
aufmerksam und verändern sie manchmal
braucht es dramatische Impulse um eine
Debatte darüber anzustoßen worüber lange
nicht gesprochen worden ist
wenn man cancel culture googelt stößt
man auf deutschsprachigen Seiten ganz
schnell auf dieses Beispiel Lisa Eckert
ich bin kein Künstler ich bin Kunst die
österreichische Kabarettistin wurde von
einem Literaturfestival in Hamburg
ausgeladen es gäbe Sicherheitsbedenken
angeblich hätte es Bedrohungen gegeben
Eckart wurde vorher und wird immer noch
Antisemitismus in ihren Auftritten
vorgeworfen die Bedrohungen beim
Literaturfestival stellten sich als
erfunden heraus die Veranstalter hatten
wohl aus Angst vor einem Shitstorm oder
ähnlichem gehandelt sie hatten Lisa
Eckhart also erst gecancelt später
wieder eingeladen
verunsicherte Veranstalter die lieber
auf Nummer sicher gehen und Künstlern
Absagen das gilt als klassisches
deutsches Beispiel für cancel culture
ein Begriff der aus den USA
hierübergeschwappt ist Judith Rosenbaum
Professorin an der Universität in Main
beschäftigt sich schon länger mit cancel
culture
das Spektrum von cancel culture ist
ziemlich breit es kann zum Beispiel
individuell sein das heißt ich
entscheide für mich dass ich eine
bestimmte Person Kunst oder bestimmte
bitte nicht mehr konsumiere also cancele
die gleiche Entscheidung kann auch ein
Veranstalter für sich treffen also dass
er zum Beispiel bestimmte Personen
Produkte oder Kunst aus seinen
Veranstaltungen ausschließt und in einem
größeren Kontext kann eine Gruppe oder
ein bestimmter Teil einer Gesellschaft
auch für sich entscheidend Dinge zu
canceln zum Beispiel bestimmte Begriffe
im Sprachgebrauch nicht mehr zu nutzen
oder bestimmtes Verhalten nicht mehr zu
tolerieren und das alles für ein Ziel
und zwar etwas zu verändern und das
versucht zum Beispiel auch Thuja Diebel
die es auch als Troja Girl bekannt bei
Instagram und sie überlegt gerade ob sie
alle Werke von j.k rowling canceln soll
würdest du Harry Potter jetzt zum
Beispiel nicht mehr lesen oder nicht
mehr schauen die Filme ich kann nur von
mir persönlich sprechen ich glaube nicht
dass ich noch jemals einen Cent in ihre
Arbeiten stecken werde zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt sage ich das also solange da
nicht ein Statement kommt der Einsicht
der wirklichen Art der Ernst ehrlich
gemeinten Einsicht bevor das nicht
geschieht kann ich das nicht mehr
unterstützen Hintergrund j.k rowling hat
in diesem Sommer mehrere Tweets
veröffentlicht mit Genderfragen zum
Beispiel diesen hier sie hat einen
Artikel gepostet und darunter
geschrieben people human straight am
sure the used to be a word for the
people someone help me out Boom bin
wimpant mumot und sie meinte natürlich
women und macht sich darüber lustig und
viele haben auch darunter kommentiert
und gesagt es gibt natürlich Frauen die
nicht menstruieren also Frauen nach den
Wechseljahren zum Beispiel und eben auch
Transfrauen und j.k rowling hat auch
noch andere Tweets veröffentlicht in
denen sie die Geschlechterfrage bei
Transfrauen in einer Art und Weise
diskutiert die als transfeindlich gilt
das alles rund um j.k rowling ist
hauptsächlich auf Twitter passiert und
Troja hat das dann hauptsächlich auf
Instagram diskutiert und veröffentlicht
und es ist tatsächlich so dass cancel
culture ganz oft in den sozialen
Netzwerken passiert Diesing cancel
kölsche is the new for nomenal coming
with social media and internet
durch die sozialen Netzwerke hat jeder
eine Stimme und kann einfacher schneller
und eventuell auch mit mehr Reichweite
canceln es kann also ganz schnell gehen
dass man von bestimmten Personen
ausgeschlossen wird und dann könnt
create culture that will people Speaker
aus Angst etwas Falsches zu sagen lässt
man es lieber diese Sorge hat in diesem
Jahr zu Formulierung des Appells für
Freie debattenräume geführt die
Unterzeichner sehen cancel culture unter
anderem als Beschränkung der meinungs-
und Kunstfreiheit ein Ungeist der das
freie Denken und Sprechen in den
würgegriffen nimmt und die Grundlage des
freien Austauschs von Ideen und
Argumenten untergräbt
diesen Appell haben über 15.000 Menschen
unterzeichnet Schriftsteller Ärzte
Juristen Professoren querbeet ich habe
mit einem der Initiatoren des Appells
gesprochen Unna Kaiser und er definiert
kenzel culture ganz anders als die
anderen mit denen ich bisher gesprochen
habe das cancel culture meines Erachtens
die Methode des abwürgens von
Debatten von Äußerungen auch
künstlerischen Äußerungen satirischen
Äußerungen politischen und
philosophischen Äußerung ist bevor sie
überhaupt angehört werden konnten Gunnar
Kaiser sieht also genau die andere Seite
Menschen die gecancelt werden werden aus
dem Gespräch verbannt und es entsteht
gar keine Debatte im Fall dieser Eckart
war das ja zum Beispiel so da hat der
Veranstalter sie zuerst ausgeschlossen
ohne Gespräch und erst im Nachhinein
vielleicht auch auf Druck der
Öffentlichkeit kam es dann zum Gespräch
und sie wurde auch wieder eingeladen
aber ich frage mich wo ist denn da die
Grenze muss immer über alles gesprochen
werden ja die ganzen sind ja von unserem
Gesetz von unserem Grundgesetz sehr klar
also soweit das geht das ist immer
schwer es gibt immer Grauzonen aber die
sind ausgedeutet und die werden auch von
den Gerichten verfolgt zum Beispiel
holocaustverleugnung oder eben
Volksverhetzung sind genau die Grenzen
die wir in der Gesellschaft uns setzen
ich finde diese Grenzen sind relativ
deutlich und in einem starken
Rechtsstaat sollten die auch eingehalten
werden wir müssen die aber nicht
künstlich
sozusagen mental noch erweitern und
genau hier sehe ich ein Problem eine
Gesellschaft setzt ja Werte und Norm für
sich fest die übergesetzte hinausgehen
es steht ja zum Beispiel in keinem
Gesetz dass das Wort Moor rassistisch
ist unsere Gesellschaft hat das aber für
sich festgelegt und deshalb wurde die
Moorenstraße in Berlin umbenannt also
nur Gesetze als gr zu sehen übergeht die
Werte und Normen die eine Gesellschaft
für sich festlegt in unserem Gespräch
spricht Gunnar Kaiser auch unsere
heutige Debattenkultur an cancel culture
sorge dafür dass kaum noch offene
Debatten stattfinden und nur wenige
unterschiedliche Meinungen überhaupt zu
Wort kommen mein persönlicher Eindruck
ist aber eher dass viele
unterschiedliche Meinungen zu Wort
kommen in den sozialen Netzwerken kann
sich ja echt jeder äußern und unter ganz
vielen Post sehe ich auch lange
Diskussionen und deshalb wollte ich noch
mal mit einer Expertin darüber sprechen
Literaturwissenschaftlerin Andrea Geyer
zur heutigen Debattenkultur finde sie
ist breiter sie ist unter sie ist
vielfältiger geworden sie hätte
dynamischer geworden und damit muss man
zurechtkommen und vielleicht brauchen
wir mehr
Willen und guten Willen mit Kritik
besser umzugehen wenn das eine Debatte
wäre die man an die cancel culture
Debatte anschließen kann dann wäre ich
hoch erfreut über Kritik Verantwortung
zu sprechen und sprachliches Handeln das
wäre eine sehr wichtige und sehr gute
Debatte da sind sich alle einig mit
denen ich gesprochen habe egal ob für
oder gegen cancel culture wir sollten
mehr daran arbeiten und mehr darüber
sprechen eine gute Debattenkultur zu
haben zusammenfassend kann man sagen
cancel culture kann echt viel bewirken
und eine Gesellschaft dazu zwingen sich
mit Themen auseinanderzusetzen die sie
bisher vernachlässigt hat aber cancel
culture kann auch dazu führen dass wir
vor schnell urteilen und das bestimmte
Themen gar nicht mehr besprochen werden
mir wurde in dieser Recherche noch etwas
klar kennst du culture hängt ganz viel
mit der Sichtweise zusammen also wenn
ich jemanden in meinem Bereich kennste
heißt das nicht dass er in einem anderen
Bereich nicht genauso weiter agiert und
da kam mir der Gedanke was ist
eigentlich mit meiner Debattenkultur bin
ich nicht in einer bequemen Blase in der
alle so ähnlich denken wie ich ich
Freunde die haben ähnliche Meinungen wie
ich ich folge bei Instagram Menschen die
am ähnliche Interessen und Sichtweisen
wie ich also komme ich gar nicht ins
Gespräch mit anderen Meinungen
vielleicht kriege ich andere Meinungen
noch nicht mal mit und vielleicht geht
es euch auch so und deshalb mein
Vorschlag folgt doch auch mal Menschen
die ganz andere Meinung haben als ihr
vielleicht geht ja auch mal in den
Dialog ich würde das gerne mal probieren
raus aus meiner bubble
was denkt ihr über cancel culture
schreibt uns eure Gedanken in die
Kommentare eigentlich müsste es für die
cancel culture Mist wirklich so Karten
geben hier ist die gelbe Karte wenn du
noch mal Scheiße erzählt dann ist
Schluss da hat die Person Zeit sich zu
rechtfertigen zeiteinsicht zu zeigen und
wenn sie das nicht tut rote Karte Platz
zu erweist so muss es laufen